[Aplausos]
[Música]
o lado sexual de quem fala é o dar que
seja muito bem vindo
jamais um vídeo e o estrago de que a
enfermaria eu já tinha trazido ao canal
sony que inferno eu acho e foi um jogo
de hate absoluto e desta vez o eu
mantenho da câmara de serpa hoje
pudéssemos garrett e terminado assim ia
aguentar e com muita tosse e eu acho qo
redes vai me vai me fazer coisas boas
virão sector falar vamos lá então jogar
só vou te dar um start shetland e nível
um ok usa é o z setas para ver o marido
então vamos lá vamos ver o mário o pouco
espaço para salvar noé não é nosso amigo
senão x também não eu só deixa aprontava
e na sexta para a próxima
tá bom eu já não estava habituado a
outros jogos e ir para lá o que não
podemos faltar lhe isso ele nem eu não
deixou ler o que apareçam escrito meu
anda lá temos sabido tala e não era
nenhum obstáculo não era nenhum
obstáculo que isso porque fosse
simplesmente burro né é um privilégio
começamos bem pessoal e este o peluche
chapéu do console porque eu vou repetir
meu eu sei que vou cair mas vou repetir
o trabalho estava indo muito bem dar é
muito bom jogar este tipo de coisas
eu não vou conseguir passar daqui lá é
preciso fazer este vídeo logo pela manhã
é porque é quando os índios estão a
dormir e eles vão cuidar como o rei
depois bateu na parede e eu sou expulso
de casa por causa dele estou eu sei que
está aí não é que não era que já não
lembro eu já não me lembro é que eu
quero mesmo é a pixel a pixel estava a
correr tão bem no ataque
não não era a idéia é que na ponta tinha
que ser na ponta do orkut no ponto
li muito bem muito bem muito agora está
aqui ele não pode sentar boa
chico põe eu acho que o espetã culo
inteira eu vou passar aqui vou morrer
olha lá num verdadeiro rei do piloto um
blog onde vocês caem
a mãe como é só porque eu não salto meu
visto o sonic não é assim eu ainda
conseguia saltar mesmo que o bicho o o
ocr para 4 cuida 23 mortes na bahia um
né só comigo depois de passar isto anda
esta porcaria e não todo curar as coisas
que tu fazer é por isso que estou sempre
a morrer em meio à onda lá calma agora
falta por cima
isso não é difícil
isto definitivamente é muito pior do que
o soneto inferno muito calma e não posso
querer e agora porque porque tinha que
parecer luís com pico é como é que eu
vou passar isto é aqui né que isso ok
agora eu vou ter que abrir uma caixinha
exatamente de darque agora e não vou
poder que ir com calma vai querer que
alguma coisa já saí eu já sei que aquele
que alguma coisa já que também é gay meu
não pode ser fatal e 110 manel todo
chateado eu não sei se as custas passar
por achar que tá num clima tão bom hoje
a tentar sol e tudo bem está feliz e
contente
a culpa foi do português chegarão jogo
red robin é é a culpa foi do evento
passar é que isso isso acho que agora
vou conseguir só acalma salvas em cada
assento caramba e
e agora como é que os puxa eu passar por
aqui ó por conseguir meu ai não eu vou
sempre tocar ali meu como é que é
possível comer com calma de dar que tu
vais conseguir e porque a vida são dois
dias e com a opção por desperdiçar boa
né
morri
não importa eu tenho é que põe anda anda
calma não não espere uma coisa este aqui
este que está aí agora foi o bloco não
picos não na outra vez eu nunca perdi
algo agora
calma calma não só para este é isso
agora vou ter que faltar para isso e
agora pra aquilo se não tiver enganado
ao momento esta porcaria boa
[Música]
tem que ter atenção a caixa desta vez
porque não estou lá cal mãe só para quem
agora só para agora e vamos deixar que a
caixa passa para cá não poderia faltar
né
você só tá né busque conseguir certo não
conseguir atacar o santos sempre pelo
mesmo sítio 71 mortes muito velho e
pronto é especial já sabem qo voz
magnífico fantástico bombástico não sei
quer convites like favorito fique bem
até a próxima